Robert De Niro has some things to say about
the things other people are saying about his
new movie.
We're talking of course of Todd Phillips'
Joker, the controversial new film from Warner
Brothers and DC in which De Niro appears in
a major supporting role.
Over the course of his decades-long career
in cinema, De Niro has played everything from
hard-nosed gangsters and bullish boxers to
overprotective fathers and emotionally damaged
war vets.
He even threw down against a certain moose
and squirrel duo in a kid-friendly comedy.
"Are you talking to me?"
"No, I'm talking about you."
"Well, I'm the only one here.
So you must be talking to me."
This year, De Niro is charging right back
into the "for your consideration" fray with
the raw and gritty Joker.
While the dark take on the Clown Prince of
Crime seems primed to set the box office on
fire, Joker has also found itself wrapped
up in some surprising controversy.
The contention surrounds the rampant gun violence
that plays a part in Joker's story, with violence
and firearms tending to accompany the Joker
character in whatever form he takes.
The perceived content of the movie has inspired
some family members of the victims of the
2012 mass shooting in Aurora, Colorado, which
tragically unfolded during a screening of
Warner Bros.
The Dark Knight Rises, to pen a heartfelt
letter to the studio prior to Joker's release.
They say they're concerned that Joker may
inadvertently inspire copycat acts of violence.
"This movie is really fueling the fire for
anyone who might even be thinking about being
a copycat of a mass shooter."
The group further urged the studio to lobby
for gun reform, cease their support of public
figures who advocate for gun rights, and to
consider throwing more support behind groups
who help the victims of gun violence.
"We wanted them to have civic responsibility,
corporate responsibility, and to do the right
thing by survivors of gun violence."
That letter has left Joker's director, cast,
and studio in the hot seat as they've been
promoting the movie ahead of its October 4th
release.
In the last week alone, Phillips, Phoenix,
and Warner Bros. have all opened up with their
own particular views regarding the matter.
And now, chatting to Variety during the red
carpet event for another of his upcoming films,
The Irishman, Robert De Niro finally offered
his own take on the Joker controversy.
De Niro, who plays a talk show host named
Murray Franklin in the film, had this to say:
"I know there's controversy.
I think some of the things that were being
said about Warner Bros. giving money, not
endorsing, or whatever it was about the NRA,
I think is right."
De Niro's words about the Joker controversy
will hardly come as a surprise to folks who
have followed his work in recent years.
The actor's unflinching political perspectives
and open criticisms of the American government,
and especially President Donald Trump, have
made him a target of politicians and other
people who stand on the opposing side of those
views.
"You've called him a bully, a pig.
Threatened to punch him."
"Um."
Needless to say, it's probably a good thing
that he wasn't quite so frank in response
to the Joker controversy as he's been about
other topics.
De Niro wisely didn't use the moment to grandstand
or stump for his own views, instead simply
offering his own support of the Aurora families
and their worries.
As for the current controversy, the Joker,
despite always being shown as a homicidal
maniac, seems to inspire a sort of idol worship
mentality amongst his fans.
The character's rock-star-like aura seemed
to reach a new level with Heath Ledger's unforgettable
turn as the clown in 2008's The Dark Knight.
While the connections between that film and
the actions of the Aurora shooter remain tenuous,
many still believe the Joker served as inspiration
for the violent act.
As such, some also believe this new take on
the character may be dangerously provocative.
On the other hand, plenty of people see no
reason to worry about Joker at all, seeing
it as just another edgy comic book movie,
so this may go down as a case of much ado
about nothing.
There doesn't appear to be any movement to
stop Joker from being released, and the Aurora
families haven't called for a boycott of the
film.
They simply argue that if Warner Bros. is
going to profit off fictional gun violence,
they would do well to treat the victims of
real gun violence with consideration and support.
Warner Bros. remains steadfast that Joker
in no way attempts to portray Joker as a heroic
figure.
Amidst the controversy, the studio is urging
people to withhold judgement until they've
actually seen the film, with a spokesperson
recently offering, quote, "A lot has been
said about Joker, and we just feel it's time
for people to see the film."
As for De Niro, aside from the controversy,
he's had nothing but positive things to say
about his experiences on Joker.
As he told to Variety,
"I like Todd Phillips and Joaquin.
They're terrific to work with."
With any luck, the energy surrounding Joker
will remain similarly positive, and the film
will arrive with little more than a heady
dose of entertainment value, a dash of societal
insight, and a stream of awards season success.
But of course, we won't get a real sense of
how Joker plays until the film hits theaters
on October 4th.
Here's hoping there are happy faces all around.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.